en tunisie face à la recrudescence des
cas de contamination variés omicron le
comité scientifique de lutte contre le
courant d'un virus préconise la
prolongation du couvre-feu fait des
restrictions
rassemblements manifestations et
événements publics sont interdits
précision en tunisie de notre
correspondant maxime chimie un
couvre-feu reconduit pour deux semaines
c'est la recommandation du comité
scientifique tunisien pour freiner la
propagation inquiétante du variant
omicron le 13 janvier dernier la
présidence du gouvernement avait décrété
un couvre-feu de 22 heures à 5 heures du
matin la veille des célébrations du 11e
anniversaire de la révolution de 2011 il
avait également été décidé l'annulation
ou le report de toutes manifestations ou
rassemblements et le contrôle jupe
hassani terre avait été intensifiés dans
les espaces d'accueil qu'ils soient
privés ou publics les scientifiques
tunisien souhaiterait voir maintenu ces
mesures jusqu'à la stabilisation de la
situation épidémiologique à travers tout
le pays nouveauté dans ses
recommandations un confinement allégé
pour toutes personnes vaccinées ou non
entrant sur le territoire national
écouter face à une phase ascendante de
la situation épidémiologique
le comité a approuvé un auto confinement
pour une période de cinq jours pour les
personnes vaccinées et testées positives
notant que la période d'auto confinement
peut durer jusqu'à 7 jours lorsque les
symptômes persistent
le ministère de la santé a annoncé ce
mercredi 17 nouveaux décès
9706 contamination encore navy riche
depuis le 24 janvier dernier ce qui
porte le taux de positivité à 31 87 %